the process of replication is very
different between eukaryotic cell and a
prokaryotic cell in this video we would
look at the difference in terms of
eukaryotic and prokaryotic replication
and focus on the part of the replication
process which is initiation and try to
delineate these two process and try to
appreciate the similarities and
dissimilarities between them let's look
at prokaryotic initiation of replication
and then we move to eukaryotic
replication initiation and try to
differentiate between the two in
prokaryotes the DNA is freely moving
inside the cytoplasm right then there is
no nuclear organization so the
replication starts in the replication
origin a specific sequence with the
replication bubble forms let's look at
this process in a bit more details so
here are 245 base pair region is known
as origin of replication or or EC
looking at the sequences in lot more
details we would find there are specific
island of sequences known as a 13 mar 6
2015 4 10 names of nine more sequences
with a sequence feature of this now it
turns out that in 9 more sequences
specific proteins such as TNA a binds as
a consequence this origin of replication
the region which is around the origin of
replication they form a loop you can see
nicely the DNA a is bound to for nine
more sequence and they formed a loop
this is called the initiator selection
phase so there are
initiated selection means their
initiation machinery has to be assembled
in a proper way and that's why you need
to select a particular Regenerist
sequence feature near which the the
initiation would take place after that
there are specific components such as so
these components are known as TNA which
really loops the DNA then there is DNA C
which is nothing but auxilary protein
which loads DNA B now DNA B are
hexameric helices proteins which unwind
the DNA near the origin so you have seen
the origin of replication is now opening
up unwinding of DNA takes place and DNA
strands are getting separated by these
helices activity there are guy rays
which are ensuring that the strands
which are getting separated they don't
get super coiled so the supercoiling
problem is taken care of by kai phase
and specific polymerase such as DNA
polymerase get recruited with the
helicases and they start pulverizing the
replication bubble mostly in prokaryotes
one replication bubble forms and that
spread in both direction to replicate
the entire genome of the bacteria now
looking at this process in a bit more
details we would understand that the key
feature of the replication initiation
would differ in eukaryotes and
prokaryotes after initiation DNA
polymerase 3 especially which is the
prevalent polymers in presenting
prokaryote would take part in the
polymerization reaction or strand
synthesis reaction with the help of RNA
primer there would be a primer formation
and followed by that DNA ball tree would
perform its work and it all works like
complex DNA P SSB proteins both fuel
work like a complex so without going to
the further tea
tales of replication elongation process
or the synthesis process we would try to
look at the eukaryotic replication
initiation and try to appreciate the
difference between the two so in case of
eukaryotes the process is very different
because the DNA reminds in format of
nucleosome inside nucleus and with that
development of advanced imaging
techniques such as electron microscopy
scientists found that there are multiple
replication origin marked here in the
red arrows in the same hole in the same
cell so replication begins in multiple
locations and the whole chromosome
replication takes place but only once in
one cell cycle so we have to understand
eukaryotic cell cycle putting it into a
context of cell biology and cell
division let's look at the first step
which is the replication site selection
which is pretty much similar in case of
prokaryotes and eukaryotes but this
particular replication site selection
takes place at g1 phase where a pre
replication complex or pre RC whose main
component is origin of replication
complex or RC binds to this selected
site and this forms the pre replicative
form complex and the pre replicative
complex is present at the g1 phase at
this point of time it is in an
inactivated state so the origin cannot
fire or from the origin replication
cannot start at g1 phase at this point
of time two molecules Serie C 6 and CTD
one will bind to the over C complex
these two molecules work like a helices
loader and they have defined function
actually their level is regulated in
such a fashion that it would regulate
initiation of the replication and ensure
that only replication can takes place
once not twice in a cell cycle so as
they are helices loader they can load
the MCM helices onto its position now at
is phase we know the replication takes
place in eukaryotes right in this phase
what happens is specific s-phase cyclin
such as cycling easier to they
phosphorylate these origin of
replication complex and the
phosphorylated complex is activated it
gives us a start signal to start the
replication and helices to act on the
strands and unwind the Strand so this is
when the CD C six and CTD one is falling
off from this origin of replication
complex or pre replication complex and
this is the time when you can say the
pre-replication complexes activated and
firing firing means the helices which is
MCM two and seven known in eukaryotes
they are moving away and forming the
replication bubble several other
associated proteins such as CD c 45rpm
routine which are very equivalent to
this SSB proteins are bound in this
situation now multiple replication
bubble could form but the replication
event take place only once how it is
happening it turns out just after the
replication of a new strand is done this
pre replicative complex is getting
associated what it remains in an
inactivated state because at a
phosphorylated state the CTD 1 and CD c6
which I have introduced earlier as a
helices loader
cannot get recruited to the pre
replicative complex as they are
phosphorylated now their phosphorylation
state is actually maintained by a
cyclin-cdk complex which is the M phase
cycling or maturation promoting factor
which is a complex of cycling B and cdk1
now what happens is these maturation
promoting factor maintain high level of
phosphorylation of series c6 and CTD one
as a result they cannot get associated
with our C's but
that at the end of g2 phase and the end
of him a mitotic phase and the beginning
of the g1 phase the cyclin B is gone the
cyclin b would be degraded by anaphase
promoting complex when the kinase level
is low phosphatase can act on these
helices loader proteins and d
phosphorylate them
now once the phosphorylated they can
reassociate it with the pre replicative
complex and wait for the S phase cycling
to phosphorylate them and that is how
they can fire again so this is this
mechanism ensures that replication takes
place only once so we can clearly
understand there is a ratiometric
balance between the kindness and the
phosphatase activity which ensures the
helices loaders are phosphorylated or T
phosphorylated in has restricted window
right that is why we only have
replication initiated at S phase not in
other phases so in S phase what happens
is the phosphorylation of these helices
loader takes place which help the firing
of the origin but in other phase other
than s phase these helices loader
proteins are always in a phosphorylated
State until and unless they're
dephosphorylation they cannot
reassociate with the complex and form a
mature pre replication complex that is
how in eukaryote restriction the
initiation phase is very much restricted
into the S phase and the replication
does not occur through pure application
process is energy costly and futile and
also the polyploidy mccloy D of the
cells might get perturbed
if replication occurs this is how using
a beautiful molecular mechanisms using
kinase and phosphatase cell ensure that
replication in eukaryote takes place
only once that's pretty much conclude
the video about this topic I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe
and I'm also present in an academy which
is India's biggest learning platform and
I'm a member there so you can always
access to my course and
direct one-to-one with me if you want to
interact with me you can take a plus
subscription which is pretty cheap you
can take a monthly subscription and then
you can use my referral code ap 10 for
getting 10% discount so hope to see you
guys soon and do let me know in comments
how do you like my video thank you